all right violent protests rocked Puerto
Rico overnight as new details emerged of
the corruption scandal surrounding the
governor thousands of demonstrators
demanding the resignation of governor
Ricardo Rocio clashed with police this
follows revelations of a profane and
derogatory group chat targeting critics
of his administration CTM lead national
correspondent David Pegg know is on the
street leading to the governor's mansion
in San Juan David is he showing any
signs of stepping down at this point no
not at all in fact during the protests
last night I text the governor's
spokesman asked if he was reconsidering
his resolve to remain in office and I
was told no not at all and upon hearing
that protesters said how can he look at
what we're doing with the number of
people doing it and not reconsider this
was the front line of the protest police
are still on the scene this morning this
is where the clashes happen and that's
where our story starts there were
thousands of demonstrators who faced off
with riot police packing that narrow
street right outside governor Ricardo
ratio's mansion one of our producers was
on the front line as the confrontation
escalated he saw masked protesters
lighting Molotov cocktails some tried to
stop us from filming there were
fireworks that went off behind the
police barricade and that's when police
moved in using force firing teargas and
pushing the crowd to disperse them it is
unclear exactly who set those fireworks
off earlier in the day more than 75,000
protesters marched near the Capitol
demanding change
puerto rican celebrities flew to the
island to lead the rally including actor
Benicio del Toro and singer Ricky Martin
who is one of the people targeted with
homophobic comments in the governor's
chat room we're tired of the cynicism
women the LGBT community
disabilities
[Music]
as the marchers were moving news was
breaking from the islands center for
investigative journalism which published
the leaked chats on Saturday a new
report alleges a multi-billion dollar
corruption network is behind the chat
group where public funds were used to
influence and benefit private clients
and the Puerto Rico government it claims
the governor knew and did nothing to
stop it look in response to that
bombshell report the governor's office
just gave us a statement within the last
half hour saying the governor has turned
over any evidence he had of corruption
of the proper authorities and he
encourages other people to do so I
should tell you this morning the local
Department of Justice here on the island
is ordering the governor and 11 other
people who were involved in that low
chat to all turn over their cell phones
to the Department of Justice but Tony
puerto ricans will tell you they don't
have a lot of faith in their own
Department of Justice to reach a
conclusion that they believe is fair Wow
they were just incredible footage there
thank you very much